bonsoir en
on va les terrains au but si je vous
parle de cancer
également ce qu'on entend ces histoires
d'horreur pis ça finit généralement par
la mort ce que je me demande c'est
est-ce que collectivement on pourrait
voir so autrement
moi la première fois que j'ai été en
contact avec le moment cgt à saint
étienne de bolton
c'est juste une usine à bonheur j'ai
passé mes étés d'enfants cela à courir
d'un chantier est juste heureuse c'était
une journée comme les autres je rentre à
la maison pour aller chercher je sais
pas quoi probablement une bonne forme et
une couleuvre une grenouille qui toute
la famille était là
tout le monde a arrêté par les nets et
tout le monde avait les yeux rouges
je retournais d'or j'ai fait comme si
rien n'était mais honda
j'avais une boule immense je savais
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui marchait
pas elle savait pas quoi j'imaginais
bien que p g ça l'était ma mère était
atteinte du cancer
en dix ans elle a eu deux fois puis la
troisième c'est lui qui lui a
posteriori quand je pense à tous ceux
qui étaient panique un ou deux lots de
ben oui c'est la première fois qu'on a
un contact avec la finitude puis le fait
que si pau juste quelque chose
d'abstrait
il y avait toute la dimension de
l'inconnu qui de l'impuissance profonde
chez moi ça s'est traduit par une espèce
de d'assiduité féroce dans l'auto-examen
des seins
contre le cancer je pouvais pas faire
grand-chose mais me taponner les seins
une fois par mois ça j'étais capable et
je les fais assidûment à partir de l'âge
de 16 ans tous les mois sauf un
j'ai manqué le mois de septembre 2010 il
jetait dans mon bain est en jeu du
combat on va le faire tout ce qui est
bien quand ça fait longtemps qu'on
faisceau on sait comment ça marche on
connaît ses seins puis quand on arrive à
des choses compte qu'il devrait pas être
l'eau mais on les reconnaît
qui quand j'arrivais en dessous du sein
droit ce que je tâtais c'était gros
comme une pils et puis je savais que ce
n'était pas normal
je sortie du bain j ai consulté d'autres
tard google
j'ai fini par trouver quand c'est dur
non mobiles
non douloureux qui gros c'est mieux de
consulter
alors j'ai
sauté des diapos je vous présente ma
mère
donc une fois que j'ai eu à appeler à la
clinique j'ai pris rendez vous
j'avais fait tout ce qu'il fallait je le
savais mais soir là quand je me couche
et ça m'a pas aidé à dormir
est ce ça durait pas ma 46 jours
46 jours qui m'en parlent comme 45 parce
que rapidement je me suis retrouvé
passablement seul j'en pouvais plus de
me faire dire de rester positive
puis l'heure quand je sais d'où ou d'où
partaient les gens avec feu c'est pas
compliqué c'est comme ma soeur chaperon
rouge les enfants ont peur du grand
méchant loup que les adultes on part du
gros méchant crabes
sauf que moi quand c'est arrivé mon tour
même si je l'avais dit ben des fois
belles du monde est restée positive dans
l'instant présent faire de la méditation
toolkit
quand c'est arrivé à moi
ce que j'entendais c'est comme si les
gens me disaient dormir alors que moi
j'étais tendu sur le bord de l'eau dans
l'obscurité la plus totale
puis que j'entendais les pots 2 millions
de gros méchants crabe autour de moi
j'adore peau très bien
la seule personne qui m'a aidé pendant
cette période là c'est mon ami d'enfance
marie-claude ce mort
à ce moment-là est traversé une récidive
du même cancer qu'on allait me
diagnostiquer plus tard elle est
apaisante pour moi parce qu'elle n'avait
pas peur de ma peur
ça s'éteignait
quand je lui disais que j'avais peur de
ne pas être capable d'amener mes enfants
en majorité que je voulais pour leur
faire vivre la même chose que moi
j'avais vu vécu
à me disais pas de rester positif ni de
boire du jus hiver
quand je lui disais que j'avais par la
chimio que je me sentais pas capable de
vivre ce que ma mère avait vécu
elle ne disait pas qu'on ait jamais
prouvé au dessus de nos forces
non à 12h04 ce sera pas une partie de
plaisir mais tu dois être capable ça se
fait
puis le 30 novembre quand je suis
revenue chez moi après mon premier
traitement de chimio que j'avais les
effets secondaires comme annoncé
mais un
bon spire qu'est ce que j'avais imaginé
par claude avait raison et la france
comprenne bien je suis en train de dire
que ça existe des effets secondaires
terrible ça existe ce que je dis c'est
que ce que ma mère a vécu à 35,1 mais ce
pays à 35
aujourd'hui grâce à la recherche ce que
la plupart des gens vivent ça ressemble
plus à ce que marie claude et moi on a
vécu
mais dans l'inconscient collectif qui
restait sur la même image qui a 35 1
et ça pour moi c'était fondamental il
faut des farces parce que quand on
arrive à un diagnostic
ou bien on a le combat de sa vie à mener
ou bien on retourne au travail qu'il
faut faire comme si rien n'était alors
que des fois ça fait des semaines des
mois qu'on dort avec des gros méchants
crabe repos dans le meilleur
et c'est là que j'ai eu l'idée de marie
claude simard pour toutes les femmes qui
sont en pré diagnostic parce que ce
qu'elle avait fait avec moi c'était pas
de la grande magie avait accueilli ma
détresse avait normalisé ce que je
vivais puis elle avait dédramatisé des
perceptions bon flic j'avais
cette idée lors commencé avec ce pays en
dehors de ma tête le 31 décembre 2018
autour de 17 ans je sortais des vraies
richesses sauf c'est la boulangerie la
plus exquise de sherbrooke et
probablement de tout l'univers
et comme le chaperon rouge j'ai décidé
de prendre le raccourci puis d'aller par
les petites ruelles sombres et là j'ai
rencontré non pas le loup j'ai rencontré
une autre marie-claude
marie-claude bats ta
je la connaissais pas ce qu'on avait
déjà travaillé sur un projet en femme
l'année précédente
et 7 marie-claude là je savais qu'elle
était chercheur
quand on s'est rencontrés je dois vous
dire fadettes un peu surréel pour elle
imaginez ça c'est la veille du jour de
l'an vous rencontrez une connaissance
avoua branca le cancer puis à partie sur
fly super excitée par une idée de
marie-claude au pluriel qui a veut
savoir comment ça marche un projet
pilote
les thébains finalement parlé de son
comité passer un partenaire en recherche
le dit mais moi je connais rien là
dedans
et là me dit fais moi confiance je te
rappel en janvier
j ai fait confiance puis de cette petite
ruelle sombre là il n'est d'abord un
nouvel ami city puis ensuite pendant
toute l'année qui a suivi
marie claude a travaillé d'arrache-pied
pour amener toute la profondeur
scientifique à l'idée que j'avais eue
elle les autres passez un partenaire de
notre comité m'ont appris que pour faire
partie d'une équipe de recherche j'avais
pas besoin d'une expérience scientifique
j'avais juste besoin de mon expertise de
la vie avec la maladie
ce comment ça se traduit le partenariat
passé à 1 recherche d'un parent et de
vente dans une équipe où on était
plusieurs patients on nous questionner
on consultait sur de la documentation
qui allait être remises à des patients
pour qu'ils puissent faire un choix
éclairé sur des options de traitement
dans la documentation partout il était
question de 3 % de risque de récidive
un moment donné il ya une patiente qui
dit
pourquoi on parle pas de 97 % de chances
de survie sans récidive
et leurs chercheurs cliniciens qui est
avec nous
moi je n'ai jamais vu ça comme ça ouais
c'est mon idée que je veux faire ça avec
mes patients dorénavant fait que le
partenariat patients si pau du rocket
fiennes fils juste de couvrir l'angle
mort des chercheurs celui de la vie avec
la maladie un autre exemple j'étais dans
une équipe où je devais raclée des
patientes qui avaient traversé le même
cancer que moi j'ai eu je dois dire que
le cancer de 5 g us d'un cancer qui
touche moins de demandes qui ont un
poids très bons pronostics au départ or
je rappelle des patientes également
déniché avec une dame on téléphone pm10
vous avez sauvé le cancer du sein jouer
à dix pôles triple négatif joaillier qui
vous est pas morte
non
et à la fin de l'appel cette dame là me
dis que juste le fait de me parler salut
apporté beaucoup d'espoir mais moi ça me
donnait beaucoup d'énergie pour
continuer à faire ce que je fais ça crée
du sens c'est ce que j'avais vécu ça
pouvait en aider d'autres
parfait pour moi une autre chose qui est
vraiment intéressante en recherche comme
passer un partenaire c'est tout ce qu'on
apprend
saviez vous que le cancer c'est une
histoire de jedi et de harry potter je
vous raconte
les jedi toutes leurs harnais notre
système immunitaire les globules blancs
les cellules tueuses sont incapables
d'éliminer l'ennemi parce qu'il a revêtu
une cape d'invisibilité
d'harry potter et les fabuleux
chercheurs sans emprunt de trouver le
moyen de désactiver la cape
d'invisibilité pour que l'armée de jedi
casse le temps faire
c'est très formidable une autre chose
qui est intéressant c'est quand on voit
nos idées à périr le 1er octobre dernier
j'ai eu le privilège
de voir mon idée de marie claude simard
pour tout ceux réalisés la fondation
québécoise cancer du sein entre l'idée
entre autres à cause du travail
scientifique le mercure devait faire et
puis boulaye ont lancé une ligne et au
bout de cette ligne là ceux des femmes
comme marie claude et moi qui réponds en
a d'autres qui accueillent leur détresse
qui normalise qui vivent ils et en prime
ces femmes là sont formés pour les
guider les guider vers de l'information
qui vollard éviter de passer des nuits
blanches sur google
ces chants
tous à être capable d'apprendre
incapable de participer à la recherche
sentir de son expérience fera quelque
chose c'est devenu quelque chose
d'important pour moi c'est devenu mon
occupation à temps plein je veux
m'impliquer dans 56 mais les affaires ma
famille vous dirais trop et
pour moi c'est si important c'est parce
que j'ai la conviction profonde que si
on veut des meilleurs soins des
meilleurs traitements il faut que les
chercheurs cherchent pis pour qu'ils
trouvent ça prend des gens pour
participer à leur recherche
saviez vous que il ya seulement 3 % de
toute participation aux essais cliniques
en oncologie
qui loge parle pas de l'iniquité fel
fait qu'une femme à montréal puis une
femme à sept-îles se verront pas offrir
les mêmes options de de participer à des
essais cliniques
et comme option de traitement
et ce qu'est ce que ça change bien fait
la différence entre une sylvie breton
vivante puis une sylvie breton morte
sylvie breton c'est une femme qui avait
en 2018 en trois mots en à wendel
à c'est d'abord engagé de façon assidue
dans ses soins et c'est ce qui a permis
de s'offrir donné tu oublies n'est qu'à
une autre il y en a qui ont marché en
nature - des marchés toujours est il
qu'aujourd'hui est encore très envie
très active à leurs patients de
partenaires chercheurs sur un projet de
recherche qu'elle a initiés
si on veut multiplier les exemples comme
ça encore faut-il que les gens sachent
que ça existe est ce là dedans le
partenariat patients peuvent faire
quelque chose parce que c'est un
instrument plus un qui peut aider à
démystifier la recherche puis la
rapprocher de la population
moi par exemple je capable de parler de
la recherche capable de parler du cancer
des avancées qui au là dedans
puis je le fais pas comme une
scientifique je ne suis pas un
scientifique je le fais comme moi qui
fait que quand j'en parle à des amis ou
à des gens qui sont pas dans les cercles
d'initiés de la recherche ben on se
comprend et ça pour moi si le petit pas
dans la direction de défaire l'espèce de
rhodes voldemort qui autour du cancer
j'aimerais ça vous parlez d'une version
italienne de l'histoire du chaperon
rouge
dans cette version là
le petit chaperon rouge sentira afin
juste parce qu'elle plus futé que loue
pour moi la différence entre cette
version l'ofppt celle des frères grimm
c'est la même chose que le changement
posture qui s'est opéré chez moi par
rapport au cancer
avant jp un chaperon rouge nef dont la
survie dépend des deux bienveillant
schaefer passé par là par hasard
j'essaie d'imaginer la mort au bout
d'une histoire norman
aujourd'hui quand je pense aux quins
vertu la marque voit
c'est toute une armée de chaperon rouge
des chercheurs du passé un partenaire
déjà comme vous et moi
qui ont des expertises complémentaires
qui sont formidables
qui marchent main dans la main en
regardant le gros méchant crabe siret
des yeux
je vous assure je sur cannot gagne on
était plus faisait que le temps faire
[Applaudissements]